[Music]
foreign
happy Friday everybody I'm wearing
glasses because I have a stye
I thought I'd get that out of the way
all right
so here's a stupid infuriating idiotic
story which can only mean it bubbled up
from Academia it happened at the
University of Pittsburgh's Cathedral of
Learning where a female student was
allegedly sexually assaulted during
school hours now that's bad enough but
it gets worse students understandably
horrified demanded increased Security on
campus and one Anonymous student created
a petition that garnered 6 000
signatures asking for more security
cameras and more stringent ID access
passes the university quickly responded
with an email from the vice Chancellor
of Public Safety and Emergency
Management
remember the old rule the longer the
title the less they actually do
in the email the VC promised they would
be taking additional actions and that
would include increasing patrols and
security shifts
meaning more cops
can you guess what happened next
Hint it always happens when Common Sense
runs head first into the witless woke
stupid destructive outrage see the woker
like that drunken [ __ ] speeding
southbound down a Northbound Highway
eventually causing destruction of
someone else who was doing the right
thing
and so a backlash came from students who
claimed the increasing police presence
would threatened the safety of students
of color
as opposed to you know want to be
rapists
you know I didn't realize Pitt was a
school for the mentally challenged what
did these students have to do to get
admitted sketch a turtle or a pirate
I tried that
so
after a sexual assault some students
were more concerned over the presence of
police than the presence of a rapist
of course this is what happens when the
media distorts the odds of police
shootings college kids prefer rapists
classrooms aren't safe during school and
cops are as popular as a fart in a hot
tub
and I know that I've done a lot of
research in that area
which reminds us college campuses are
not just gun-free zones they're also
brain free zones
so here you've got a microcosm of what
you're seeing now in every city
microcosm means a small sample of a
bigger problem like Joy behar's small
toe
that's pretty good
yes could use a lap
she never fails with crime out of
control and with so many female victims
where are the feminists why are they so
afraid of calling out repeat Thugs who
viciously brutalize women even when
attackers are arrested they're let free
immediately and they're they're only
punishment is that they're late for
their next attack
here's the reason the female victim is
now secondary to the Mantra of systemic
racism
for a long time it's been a dog fight
for first place on top of the victim
totem pole but sorry gals being
considered racially oppressed is the
equivalent of drawing a royal flesh in
poker no other hand can trump it so if
you're in the wrong group you can't be a
victim even when you're a victim and if
you complain of course you must be
racist in the world of social justice
violent felons can be busted and
released without bail in hours because
Society did it to him and after each
senseless attack as always the perps
lengthy rap sheet is longer than a
receipt from Walgreens
don't dare add any more police because
that'll hurt feelings so they can have a
safe space from alternate ideas but not
rapists using their logic if you're at
an ATM late at night you're better off
if the guy behind you is wearing a ski
mask than a cop's hat
fact is crime's out of control because
any attempt to reduce it is seen as
racist it's a new hierarchy no more good
over evil but racial Justice over actual
Justice
so after this moronic backlash the
person who launched the petition deleted
it and then apologized like a fool
quote the fact that it seems like more
campus cops are being added because of
something I did makes me a monster and I
know that
now in a normal world meaning a world
without progressives these very exact
words would be coming out of the
suspect's mouth so I'll repeat the words
the fact that it seems like more campus
cops are being added because of
something I did makes me a monster and I
know that the 18 year old then adds I
don't think I'll come back to campus
Monday I'm considering academic leave or
transferring to another school if that's
possible
well how about preschool
this poor thing needs another chance to
grow up
[Applause]
guests
this cane has proved he's more than able
a little bible humor people
co-hosting Fox and Friends Weekend will
King
her favorite candy is butterscotch minus
the butter
box dudes
you're mad at me
they say less is more but this more is
Never Enough author of so you've been to
sent to diversity training Chadwick
Moore
[Applause]
this is a great intro that I never saw
she's like Canada
white always cold and people often
forget she's there
oh my God it's really good
yeah you look like a very professional
psychiatrist right now I kind of am in
my spare time yeah that is does this
piss you off this whole thing I mean is
this this is like it's hard to make
jokes because at the base of this is a
sexual assault obviously but people
actually saying we don't want protection
from rapists because that might offend
people yeah yeah absolutely I mean you
don't have to be like super pro cop to
choose seeing a cop over being raped I
think that's a pretty normal way to make
that decision and that you're absolutely
right that the statement did sound like
it came from the rapist yeah
I'm a monster and I I may never return
to this campus again
that would actually be a great point of
view from that guy yeah you probably
shouldn't come back and he is a monster
uh I think it's just absolutely insane I
um and again I'm not somebody I think
that there's plenty of things that you
know are crimes that shouldn't be crimes
uh I think that police need to focus on
real crimes up at the top of that list
is definitely a violent sexual assault
yeah so I think it's um you know hope
somebody talks to the kid hope the kid
has somebody to talk to yeah I mean did
he show that statement to anyone before
he wrote it for proofreading I have no
idea and I still don't even know the
whereabouts of the rapists if they've
got any like that this story apparently
on the bottom of the priority yeah
find out what he looked like you know
Julie I'd be happy to see a police
officer or a stripper dressed as a
police officer rather yeah no I think
they're going to suit them quickly
because the description was really
precise he's wearing a backpack no he's
black he's black he had short curly hair
I think a purple shirt I saw just the
backpack because I don't see color yeah
you don't but you know what you probably
saw the majority of the press I did I
saw the police I saw the with the police
description but I bet it didn't get to
where you saw it oh it definitely didn't
get to you because you won't actually
believe what I thought when I saw the
headline woman sexually assaulted in
Pitt's Cathedral of Learning I was like
Brad Pitt
it's actually assaulted somebody so then
once I realized that wasn't true I was
quite relieved but then I actually read
the story and I was enraged because it's
disgusting because I constantly Rage
Against the woke that don't support our
police and our police are under attack
why because of not only politicians but
kids that are being raised to become
anti-cop and these college students are
a perfect example of how Despicable it
is that we're raising people that don't
believe in law enforcement they're there
to protect you but yeah no having a cop
on campus is way more offensive than
being sexually assaulted in a stairwell
you know what it is uh uh will it really
is an achievement what what what Julie
said there was something actually
truthful to what she said it's a
surprise really yes yes I know yeah but
it is like an achievement of the radical
left that now we live in a world where
young people believe the police are more
harmful than criminals that is something
that you try to push into society in
order to destroy it yes but it's not
something that people actually believe I
think that's something people pretend to
believe that cops are actually a threat
to their life this story is full of fear
from top to bottom but it's not actually
fear of cops nor fear of the racist or
the rapist it's being feared of being
called a racist it's fear of being
ostracized so the kid that wrote that
letter he talks about and he's going to
the greatest links possible for
self-flagellation I'm a monster I'm
taking a leave of absence I may transfer
does anybody else need anything else
here what can I do to keep them Bob from
coming after me he's more terrified of
being ostracized than he is of a racist
a rapist mixing those words but one last
note which I didn't know until you just
said this I must have read the same
story that Julie read because all I saw
as a description of the perpetrator was
a backpack yeah because well the thing
is I was I couldn't find anything and
then uh one of the staffers went and
looked and found the police report and
it's very specific how the person looks
but that that you don't see that they
left it out because I'm telling you it
was a Black Backpack they did not
mention the race I'm telling you I read
it a few times thank God they said that
looking for Brad Pitt in the article
they should they should round up
everybody with a black backpack yeah I
also saw that the kid that wrote that
letter was an English major
I know okay I only saw one of his essays
I don't think it's gonna work yeah it's
kind of sad the kid the kid thinks his
life is ruined because what he did was
help get more security to the campus and
for that he thinks he's the monster is
one of the most amazing thing Chadwick I
bet you wish this was in your book I do
I do when did you book him out uh it's
out now it's not oh I've got a copy for
you I can't wait to give it to you well
I'm really busy but anyway
I know I have an eye infection so I
won't be beating anything for a number
of years
um the thing is that they will still
obviously have no shame on depending on
the police to bring in this perpetrator
but they don't want to see them on
campus what if their phone gets stolen
well because who do they think is going
to track this guy down a crack team of
gender studies professors gonna do the
forensic work no they need the police
officers it was very much like when if
you remember when New York City Gay
Pride said that cops can't march yeah
they can't be seen it's too triggering
but they will still be required to do
the security so it's like we don't want
to see you but please do the work that
is vital to us do you know this reminds
me of the politician in Seattle who um
was 100 behind to funding the police
until somebody started throwing human
excrement on her porch that's right what
did you call the cops I remember that
they wanted to do forensic testing on
the feces
not mine
I don't give that stuff away for free
it's disgusting why are you looking at
me
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else